(speak in foreign language)
- Gentlemen, again,
congratulations on the film.
It is so incredible and congratulations
on the SAG nominations.
And really you guys are
getting so much praise for it.
But have to ask you about
how did you guys kind
of reconcile the fact
that such an American film was nominated
for best foreign language
at the Golden Globes?
I mean, I'm sure you
appreciate to be honored
but it seems so strange
for such an American story.
- Yeah, you know it's weird
because in the back of my mind like
when I think about language,
when I talk to my mom and dad
we don't always connect
using Korean or English.
- [Isaac] We just had gestures
and facial expressions
because we have this
natural language barrier.
So I've always felt like
there should be no distinction of language
but that we're all really
speaking human to each other.
You know, even if we're not
speaking English to each other.
So when this happened and
there's this delineation
with language, it feels like
a, like an external sort
of category for me, which
I don't always understand.
And more, I just feel more sympathy
to the people who really
feel a lot of offense to it
and feel like, you know, once
again, we're being treated
as foreigners and all this
stuff that I totally understand.
But in my view, the characters
in this film speak human.
And that's what they're
doing to each other,
with their faces.
- [Isaac] You see it in
Ye-ri, you see it in Steven
and Alan.
And that's what I hope for this film,
that everybody will watch it
and not think about language.
They don't even know if
they're reading subtitles
because they get lost
in the humanity of it.
- Well I mean, if
they're watching the film
I don't see how they can't.
And I think that's spared out in me
in this film is still certified
fresh critics, audiences.
I'm so glad that more folks
are gonna get a chance
to see it.
But Alan, I'm gonna have to ask you.
As people start seeing it, you know
you got to get to go to the SAGS now.
Are you excited to maybe, you
know, do your like zoom party
are you getting your suits
ready for award season?
- Yes.
(laughs)
- What did you think
when you got nominated?
Can you give me your reaction?
- I'm like, "Yei"
- That was the exact dance.
- Was that the exact dance?
I love that.
And I also love that this
is a film, like you said
as folks get a chance to see it,
it sorta continues I think a great trend
that, you know director Bong talked about
when he was doing the
awards tour for "Parasite."
Is folks being able to sort of like
hurdle the one inch barrier
subtitles to open up
an entire world of cinema.
And Steven, I just
wanna talk to you as far
as like the Korean influence here.
I mean, you've worked with
some of these filmmakers.
Which films or filmmakers are
you hoping folks will discover
thanks to what you guys have done here
and films like "Parasite"?
- Oh man.
You know, I just hope, I don't know.
I think there's so many wonderful talents
kind of everywhere.
I see so many new Chinese
films being really beautiful.
Korean films there's I
think "House of Hummingbird"
is a really wonderful film.
- [Steven] "The world between us"
is a really wonderful film too.
Yeah. I mean, I hope it
just opens up a dialogue
of understanding that like
these, like director Bong said,
that these subtitles are just
literally tiny, tiny barriers
of examining the humanity
that all of us share.
And so hopefully we're headed there.
- Yeah. I really love it.
And I love the fact that,
you know, we're able
to cover these films and
really get to talk about it.
Because yeah, it just opens
up a whole different world
of cinema and it seems
like it'll never be ending
cause there's always different
types of stories to be told.
But Isaac, I have to talk
to you about this one
because this is an immigrant story.
And one thing I remarked on it is it's one
with very little racism throughout it,
which I think it was an incredible choice
because so often immigrant tales
are very much rooted in that.
And I thought that was
such an interesting choice
to tell this story.
And I wondered at what point
did you make that decision
or is that just how it played out?
- I made that decision early on.
I'm glad that you liked that choice.
Because for me, that was kind of a gamble.
Like I knew that people would
be expecting a lot of racism,
to be honest.
I thought with a story like
this, you often see that.
- [Isaac] But first of all,
that wasn't my experience growing up.
Like, I did encounter racism.
But most of the time my
existence was not defined
by that racism.
And it wasn't defined by
that in my own family.
Most of the time I'm just
trying to relate to my family,
to be honest.
And then my interactions
with the community
there are so many that
just ended with love.
Maybe it started with
friction, but it really ends
with people seeing each
other for who they are.
So I wanted the film to
function in that way.
I didn't want it to just knee jerk say,
well these are white southerners
that they're gonna be racist.
Like I think that in
itself is problematic.
So yeah, I hope that resonates somehow.
- I thought it was really incredible.
And again, it really
allows you to just focus in
on the family and the dynamic.
And one of the great dynamics
of course, is Steven and Alan
and the way you guys
had to do that together.
So I wanna go back to the
whole audition process, Alan
because I do know that
you very much stood out.
So do you remember that
day when you were working
with Steven and you knew
you were trying to audition
for it at all?
- Yeah. I remember some of it.
We went to "Plan B."
I went into a room and that Steven the...
- Casting director?
- Yeah.
- Casting director and
Steven taught me like
something called (speaks
in foreign language).
- Oh, that's right.
Oh, you got a good memory.
- All right, Steven,
what's this real quick?
So I wanna hear all about it.
- Oh it's like Korean cogs.
- Oh, nice. Oh, that's dope.
Oh, so do you like bang
them against each other?
- Yeah you try to flip the other person's
and you get to take it.
But that's so keen that you remember that.
I actually forgot about that.
So you have a better memory than I do.
Was I scary though, Alan?
Like when I came back into
the room as was your dad.
- No, not really.
- Dang.
- Alan's never scared.
- Never scared.
- Never seen him scared.
- I mean, and I...
- People agreed that
Alan said Isaac was like,
hey you know that...
like after we did the
end props he was like
"You know, that were,
this was pretend right?"
We're done now.
And then Alan was just
like, "Yeah, yeah. I know."
(crew laughs)
No in real life, I'm like "That was fake?"
- Was that when, you knew, Isaac
that he was the kid when he was
just like, "Yeah, I got it."
Was that the moment where you're like
"All right, we're good."
- I mean, he convinced me, he fooled me.
I thought, you know he was
really scared or something,
but then it turns out you know,
he's just in the scene, he's acting.
So when you see that, you know
that you're gonna be all right on set.
(speaks in foreign language)
- First of all, congratulations
on the nominations.
It's been incredible,
especially the SAG nominations.
I'm just curious, what are you...
I'll start with you, Ye-ri,
what are you thinking
about the award season?
Are you getting excited
to, you know, come in
and sort of I guess, meet
the glitterati of Hollywood?
(speaks in foreign language)
- Enjoy it. It's really incredible.
And I think even more
people are gonna start
to appreciate it.
But let's backtrack just a little bit.
Yuh-Jang I'll start with you.
This is one of the first big things
I think a lot of Americans
have seen you in.
I, you know, spotted you in "Sense8",
but for other folks this may
be their first introduction.
So I'm just curious.
What made you sign on to do this one?
- Because of the friends.
Now, you know, when you
get old, you can just focus
just the one thing.
Not when you are young.
But you can just, okay, this is script.
- [Yuon] Script will be good for me.
Good for my future or something like that.
But now after 60 years old
I'm just focusing only people.
The one I love.
The one I appreciate or the
one who's very precious to me
that my precious friend
introduced the script.
And then of course the script wasn't good,
then maybe I would say no.
But while I was reading it
and then I felt very
genuine and authentic.
So I said...
Middle of the reading I called her,
"Is it real story of him?"
And she said, "Yes."
So I said, "Okay, I'll do it."
That's the start.
- I love that.
I love that so much
because it came from a
place from the heart.
And you can tell that when
you see the performances
because they're so touching
and they're so moving.
You can tell that everybody
became a family on set
and Ye-ri, Monica, especially
I find your performance of her
to be such a delicate thing.
Because she keeps her
emotions close to her chest
at the beginning and she
slowly unravels them.
So I wondered if you could talk about
how you played that to
give it a slow reveal
of how she felt.
(speaks in foreign language)
That's so beautiful.
And yeah, that's exactly it.
Because when you hit that climax,
you especially spiel in it.
I mean, it really hits home
the whole emotion of the film.
Before I get out of here, Yuh- Jung
I wanted to talk about Alan.
Because I just got done interviewing him.
And from the first time I met
him at like "Sundance" to now
he is just effervescent and just
like this ball of kid
energy, which is infectious
but see like a little
hurricane, it's hard to contain.
So talk about containing
the hurricane to give
that beautiful performance
that you guys were able to do.
Cause I'm sure there's a
lot of work on your side
to make that happen as well.
- Sorry to disappoint you.
I didn't work a lot with him.
It's all Isaac's job
Because the director
knows how to control him.
First I was scared to just
meet him because I heard
that he has not having
experienced to acting.
- [Yuon] So I felt, "Oh my goodness
what I'm going to do with this boy?"
And then, Oh, no, no, no, no.
He really made me disappointed.
He memorized the older line,
and then Isaac asked him to do with me,
just the unit get over the line together.
And then he was perfect
memorizing all the line.
And then after that Isaac
asked him to do this.
You need some kind of
shot I think from him
just to smile, look at me and smile.
And this kind of smile or that smile
and then look at the camera
and then give you a Brown
face or something like that.
It's all editing's job.
It's all Isaac's job.
(speak in foreign language)
(scream)
- [Jacqueline] I checked
this this morning.
I didn't know until today.
You're on a five certified,
fresh, hot streak.
Your last five films going back.
Yeah. Have all been certified fresh
which is quite a remarkable feed.
And this is all, you
know, post "Walking Dead".
And I think...
- [Jacqueline] There must've
been a lot of offers after that
and you could have gone a
lot of different directions
but I think looking at the
films you did, everything
from "Okja" and "Mayhem"
and "Sorry to bother you."
And now "Minari" "Burning."
Those are specific choices.
So talk about how you made
the choice to do those films
or how you wanted to work
with those filmmakers.
- You know, it's strange
because you're asking me now
from a kind of a retrospective
lens and, you know,
maybe at this point kind
of compiled like a story
to tell about what happened
and how made these choices.
But in those moments, like, I don't feel,
I don't know if I had agency like that.
I probably did.
I certainly said no to things that I felt
like were just other versions`
of things that I've tried before.
But I think in a lot of it
is, you know for me, I'm just,
I was really trying to find myself.
I was really trying to find out who I was
and kind of get to play in roles
that allowed me the space
to express the fullness
of not me per se, but of a character.
You know, as an Asian-American actor,
prior to "Walking dead", if I
had any opportunities at all
it was really mostly to
service larger narratives
or kind of be kind of like a,
you know, like a plot point
by which to weave the
main character around it.
So I wanted to be the main character
that gets to have the plot
points to weave around.
And, you know, even with
"Mayhem" I'm so thankful to them
for giving me my first chance
at like a leading role.
- [Steven] It wasn't a big
budget and we started in Serbia.
But we had some really wonderful
people with us, you know,
Samar was incredible. Joe was great.
And, just to kind of do
that and flex that muscle
was attractive to me.
And then "Okja" I think was, you know,
who wouldn't work for a director Bong?
You know I'm a huge fan.
And so, you know, him reaching
out and giving that part
to me was extraordinary and painful
because K was you know,
very much something
that I was at the time.
I was just somebody straddling two worlds
and being unable to service either one.
And I think going through that experience
I wasn't necessarily super conscious of
what I was participating in.
I would, but like I realized
halfway through, I was like
"Oh man, like, this is
kind of how I feel."
And it is a painful realization.
- [Steven] And then "Sorry to bother you"
was really wonderful of
just kind of speaking
from an Asian-Americans perspective.
Even though it wasn't explicitly,
but just in a different way of...
- You're "Mr. Steal,
your girl" in that movie.
That's what I love.
Like she is, was the guy that was coming
to slot into the DMS to check on it.
I thought that was so brilliant.
- You know, that's Boots, you know.
And I guess on a larger note, what I feel
like is happening when
you think about, you know
Gong and then you think of an Isaac.
I'm just really attracted to people
that are singular people, you know.
There's no other Boots Rileys.
There are no other Bongs or
(mumbles) or Isaac Chungs.
It's really just these people
that I gravitate towards
that we can share an experience in a story
that they've crafted that feels so unique.
I remember reading, "Sorry to bother you"
and like certain people reading
and be like, "What is this?"
And then me reading, it'd be
like, "I gotta to do this."
Like I have to.
Who can write like this?
Who has a mind like this?
And when I see that I'm in.
So that's kind of where I'm at with that.
- I love that you put it
like that cause you're right.
And I'm sure you just
go on from job to job,
trying to do interesting work but
when you can look back on
it, it really is incredible.
And that was so cool.
And I was like, getting ready for this
to kinda chat about that one too,
because the New York times profile I read
where you kinda talked about this
and the identity and the
choices that you made
I found it was just so
fascinating and interesting.
Because the character
that you play in "Manari"
is just like, not about
multi-faceted at all.
He is just like a man on a mission.
One focus, one goal,
not listening to really
any of the noise on the outside.
And I think that's way
more difficult I think
than trying to play a
multi-faceted character
in some ways to add that humanity.
So talk about that balancing act.
- Yeah. Jacob was an interesting person
to kind of climb into the mind of...
Not because I didn't
understand them at all
but because I think
you're kind of exploring
the pain of being alone.
- [Steven] The pain of isolation
in him, at least for me.
And I think that's where I
found a lot of his humanity.
That he means well and he wants things
and he loves his family
and he desperately wants
to provide for them.
But he doesn't know how
to separate his role
and his duty and his
function from the love
that he can also show his family.
And oftentimes that function
and duty takes the role of love
that he shows for his family
and his family doesn't
know how to deal with that
or accept that because
maybe it's not really
the best way to convey love.
To just play your part.
And in that way, I think, you know
Jacob from the outside
looking in might look
and feel like a patriarch
that's dragging his family
through his own ego.
And ultimately it is to some degree.
But from his perspective
he's also just trying his best
to provide for his family.
- [Steven] And he's
doing it in the only way
he's ever known how.
And that's to give his body
and mind up to that struggle.
And so I think in some
ways he feels deeply alone
and isolated from his own family
because they can't see what
he's providing for them
or that's what he feels
like they can't see.
So yeah, that was kind
of the journey of Jacob.
- And it's interesting too, obviously
because this is semi-autobiographical
and I think even Isaac
would be able to say
that some of the stuff that
he experienced was stranger
than the fiction that he put on screen
but in the end playing his dad
and that's another delicate dance too.
So I was just wondering
if you guys had any
conversations with that.
I'm sure he had to give
you a bit of freedom
with it a little bit, but
also he wanted to make sure
that it was true to the man
that he was trying to be.
- Well, you know, to be quite honest
he actually left a lot of space.
He left a lot of space.
He had no specifics on
how his dad needed to be.
And in fact, he never brought that up
as something that he
needed to be checked off.
You know, he wrote something
so true in my opinion
that was so human that
I think it created space
for a lot of people to have
come in and taken that role
and imbued it with the
things that they knew.
It just happened to be
that, you know, Isaac
and I share a lot of
our experiences together
of an immigrant life of isolation
and of also understanding
you know, what it means to be a father.
- [Steven] And so, yeah, I think that
I think that really speaks
to him on a larger note
the graciousness of someone
like Isaac, you know.
As I get to know him more and
as I get to see how he thinks
and how he's constructed this
film and written this film
I peel back all those layers and I realize
what's at the beating heart of it all.
And it's just someone that
like deeply deeply cares
about others and about
humanity in that way.
And he cares not only about the
characters that he's created
but also he cares deeply
about even the audience.
About making sure that there is no barrier
to accessing these people in this story.
And it's really about connection
- I guess you'd have to be. Yeah.
Cause you wouldn't wanna
be stifled in that.
It's really incredible too
cause it feels so lifted.
It's even more incredible to realize
that it was just a creation
that you guys were able to do
from taking it from
the page to the screen.
I guess I have to definitely
ask you about this one
in the fact that folks
are now gonna finally
get to see it and the scene.
I guess it were that
you ended up with Ye-ri
towards the end.
It's probably one of the
most climactic things,
but without spoiling it,
just talk about her as a scene partner
and how you guys were
able to work that out.
Because in a lot of ways,
the movie lives or dies
by that scene.
- Wow, thanks. I'm so
glad you enjoyed that.
You know, I can't say enough
good things about Ye-ri.
She's incredible.
- [Steven] Her role in this
it's so meta too, you know.
That particular scene...
I guess I gotta start from
how we shot the whole thing.
You know, we never
really over talked much.
We maybe talked about that
particular scene a lot
in terms of shaping what I
wanted to say in that moment
and maybe what she wanted
to say in that moment.
And we got to some place that
felt right for the two of us.
- [Steven] But beyond that,
you know, there was many times
where her and I really
just had single takes.
We kind of really lived that experience.
And the ways in which she
was honest about her approach
to Monica, in the ways that I
would talk about my approach
to Jacob and kind of the
truthfulness that we shared
between each other and
even in the disagreements
of how we saw situations
were part of it, you know.
It was part of making the
tension of those characters.
And so, yeah, I mean
I knew I could just trust her
intrinsically to be honest
and truthful all the time.
And you know, if you haven't
seen partner like that,
like that's, you're chilling.
(laughs)
- I mean, it didn't look
like y'all were chilling,
it looked pretty powerful
but I get what you're saying as far
as the work on the other side.
Last one and this one's a little bit light
but I'm just gonna put it out there.
Your character, Jacob is
like the Michael Jordan
of chicken sexting.
We are very curious if
you got good at this.
And trust me when I say this was a very
big editorial conversation
at "Rotten Tomatoes."
So please take this seriously.
We wanna know, did you get
good at telling the difference
between male and female?
- I did, I got up pretty decent.
You know actually who
probably got better is Ye-ri.
Yeti is the real...
I'm probably like the Scottie Pippin.
No, maybe I'll get all the credit
because some dumb weirdness,
but she's the real MVP, you know?
(mumbles) the real MVP.
She really knew how to do that.
I think for us, it was the
practice of practicing that
with our animal Wrangler
and also, you know, my wife
her parents also chicken sexed,
just like Isaac's parents.
And they taught us tips and tricks
and we all grow out our
thumbnails so that we could like
open their vents.
It was a fascinating time.
- Oh my gosh, I really did not expect that
to be such a thing.
So I will have to...
I literally was like
"He is not gonna say anything
about this chicken sex stuff,
y'all are morbid."
But you know what, I'm
down with that one now.
And then just like a
very last question again
just to follow up on the "Parasite."
Now you guys entering in this conversation
logical best picture nominee,
folks in my seat who do this for a living
are already talking about that thing.
Man what do you think is going
to be like this next section
when we get back into theaters?
Do you think it's just
gonna push even further?
And if so, what are you
excited to see next?
What kinds of stuff would you like
to see American audiences
come sort of import over?
- I don't know.
I mean, I think we're also...
I think for America,
what's fascinating about,
especially this film is
kind of really digging into
what's already been here, you know.
And I think that's kind of touching
on what we were facing
with "Minari" in terms of,
I think this conversation
around foreign language.
And even "Parasite."
Parasite opened many doors and
broke down a lot of barriers
on a larger, I think humanity level
of just understanding each
other in between cultures.
But their humanity that they're
expressing is unencumbered
by the American gays because
they're Korean people
and they're making it from Korea.
So they're not considering us.
Whereas our film does have to navigate
the constant consideration
of who we are in the midst of
a primarily white majority
American audience.
And so a lot of the time the
ways that that would express
is we end up explaining ourselves
or we end up telling the
audience how we are oppressed
by the majority or how the
majority factors into our story.
But the truth is we weren't
even considering that.
Because that's our story.
Our story doesn't bring
home a consideration
of the majority American
whiteness at a constant level.
It's just like, I'm me and I exist.
And this is from my point of view.
And I think it was really
cool to be at a time
where an American company in
"Plan B" and A24 can finance
and produce and make a non
English language, American film.
I mean, what a new foundation,
what a new frontier.
And I hope that, you know
if anything comes about it's that we get
to really understand
what makes America more.
All the things that have always been here,
which is just all of us.
There's so many different
things that make America.
And I'm interested in that
as a next step for us on American side.
And then beyond that the
world is just getting more
and more global anyhow.
And so, you know
hopefully we get to be human
together at some point.
(upbeat music)